مشجعي لكم راح اول العالم مو بس مشجعي
الهلال والنصر وباريس سان جيرمان انضارهم
رحله اتجه للرياض يوم 19 اللي مباراه كاس
موسم الرياضي المنتظره واللي اعلن عنها من
ايام نجوم فريقيه الهلال والنصر رح
يواجهوا النجوم نادي باريس سان جيرمان على
ستاد الملك فهد الدولي المباراه هتكون
الاولى لرونالدو في السعوديه من وقت
انضمام لنادي النصر ورئيس هيئه الترفيه مع
للمستشار تركي ال الشيخ كشف انه الدون راح
يكون كابتن فريق موسم الرياض اللي راح
ينافس النجوم باريس سان جيرمان ولبس ولبس
تحديدا رونالدو
الموسم الرياض
يلا الوعد يوم 19 مع كابتن
[تصفيق]
كي
مع الفيديو الي شفتوه قال انه المباراه
راح تكون لقاء فوق الخيال وكشف انه مدير
الفريق راح يكون كابتن خالد الشنيف
والتشكيل اللي راح يعلنها المدرب وخالد
يعبر معلم مستشار عن امنيه خلال هذه
الساعتين اتمنى ننسى الهلال والنصر ساعتين
ونصير كلنا موسم الرياض وبعد ساعتين نرجع
نوقف الهدنه في تغريده الثانيه غرد معالي
المستشار متخيل المشهد لما يفوز فريق موسم
الرياضه
ادي المباراه راح تكون المواجهه الاولى
بين رونالدو ميسي من ثلاث سنوات من وقت
مباراه دوري المجموعات بدوري ابطال اوروبا
والانتهت بفوز يوفنتوس 3 0 وقتها رونالدو
سجل منهم هدفين وبعد هذه المباراه بكام
يوم تحديدا يوم 22 راح يلعب رونالدو اول
مبارياته بتيشرت النصر امام الاتفاق
[موسيقى]